- landon mallanna is to arrive in a city
tinged with fear our flight carried only
a few dozen passengers we were all
checked for signs of fever after
arriving but kovat 19 has already made
its presence felt in Italy three days
ago this country only had a few cases of
corona virus now it's got hundreds and a
growing number of people have died Italy
is not alone South Korea and Iran have
both seen similar surges in cases today
the World Health Organization said the
world should do more to prepare for
possible endemic using the word pandemic
now does not fit the facts but it may
certainly cause fear this is not the
time to focus on what word we use that
will not prevent a single infection
today or save a single life today this
is a time for all countries communities
families and individuals to focus on
preparing the heart of this outbreak is
the region of Lombardy where a string of
towns have been shut down this is castle
postal engel ringed with roadblocks to
stop anyone entering or leaving it looks
like a ghost town in Milan the fear is
about things you can't see
tourists almost absent from the
landmarks food missing from the shelves
because of chronic buying and of course
the invisible virus the question they
ask is why here why should this city and
this region be suffering so many more
cases than anywhere else in Europe and
there are no answers yet just guesses
yeah I want to understand to experts and
scientists will give us the answers
maybe in our country there are many
checks and it's good maybe in our
country we live a very prosperous and
broad social life so we have a lot of
human contact where tactile people would
shake hands we
yes we hug in Venice which sits in
another area to have seen an outbreak of
the virus the carnival closed early
Italy is a nervous country
Adam Parsons Sky News Milan